AIRCRAFT WEDNESDAY AND CAPTURING
THAT PILOTS.
CANDIDATES WILL ALLOW THE U.S.
EXTRADITION CASE AGAINST A
CHINESE TELECOM EXECUTIVE TO PRO
SEED WHO IS ACCUSED OF
CONSPIRING TO DEFRAUD BANKS.
CHINA SAID IT IS DISSATISFIED
AND OPPOSING THE DECISION.
THE CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER IS
INVOLVED IN A SCANDAL.
HERE'S THE STORY FROM
WASHINGTON.
>> I AND MY STAFF ALWAYS ACTED
APPROPRIATELY.
>> THAT'S CANADA'S PRIME
MINORITY RESISTING CALLS FOR HIS
SESSION.
-- RESIGNATION.
HE IS HOLDING FAST TO HIS
MAINLINE OF DEFENSE.
>> MY JOB IT TO STAND UP FOR
CANADIANS.
>> HIS FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND JUSTICE MINISTER CLAIMED HIS
OFFICE LAUNCHED A CAMPAIGN OVER
MANY MONTHS TO GET HER TO DROP
CHARGES AGAINST A CANADIAN
COMPANY.
IT'S ONE OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
CONSTRUCTION AND ENGINEERING
FIRMS.
IN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE CANADIAN
PARLIAMENT.
WILSON OUTLINEDED TRUDEAU'S BOLD
FACED INTIMIDATION TACTICS.
>> THERE WERE MANY INAPPROPRIATE
CONVERSATIONS AND ATTEMPTS AT
POLITICAL INTERFERENCE THAT
OCCURRED.
I BELIEVE WHERE IT GOT MORE
HEIGHTENED WERE WHAT I DESCRIBED
AS THE VEILED THREAT.
>> IT'S A DRAMATIC FALL FROM
GRACE FOR TRUDEAU.
A YOUNG LIBERAL PRIME MINISTER
WHO GRABBED THE WORLD'S
ATTENTION THANKS TO HIS EASY
RAPPORT IS WORLD LEADS.
FRIENDSHIP WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND SPATS WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
OVER FREE-TRADE.
NOW THIS WILL GET WORSE.
>> IT'S A TEXTBOOK CASE OF
GOVERNMENT KRURPTION.
CORRUPTION.
>> TRUDEAU SAID WE DISAGREE WITH
THE FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE EVENTS.
CANADIANS WILL GET THEIR SAY.